[Musique]
printemps 2020 un péril jaune s'abat sur
la plaine de beauce comme dans toutes
les régions du nord de la loire une
invasion de pucerons a déclenché une
maladie une virose de la betterave qu'on
appelle communément la jaunisse
vous voyez des feuilles jaune foncé très
épaisse et cassante ces betteraves là
vont peu poussé
un diagnostic confirmé à l'automne à
l'arrachage beaucoup de betteraves
ressemblent à des navets c'est une vraie
catastrophe et je comprends le désarroi
des planteurs romain lhopiteau
agriculteurs bio et alexandre peut
l'aimer travier conventionnelles ont
subi cette crise mais en tire des
conclusions différentes
donc la salle et les betteraves et ça
c'était au au 20 juillet chez le
betteravier bio les signes de jaunisse
était moins apparent en 2020 ces chants
avait une couleur verte quasi uniforme
pourtant la maladie était bel et bien
présente 2020 le rendement il a été de
33 tonnes par hectare donc c'était
plutôt décevant parce que je m'étais
donné du mal à désherber manuellement
mais pas catastrophique non plus parce
que le on est sur des prix assez
rémunérateur on a une turbine logique
mais il ya certains conventionnel qui
ont fait la même chose en finale et là
c'est la catastrophe pour l'agriculture
conventionnelle la facture est
effectivement ça l'est en raison d'une
baisse de tonnage de 30 à 50% selon les
parcelles pour la région la perte allait
se situe autour de 45 tonnes soit 25 ses
1000 à 1200 euros de l'hectare qui sont
perdus pour les exploitants de la région
que les betteraviers conventionnelles
ont donc réclamé et obtenu une raie au
taux risation des insecticides
néonicotinoïdes très efficace en
enrobage de semences mais désignés par
les associations environnementales comme
des tueurs d'abeilles les acteurs auront
le choix alors deux d'utiliser ce
produit ou de ne pas l'utiliser en
fonction de leurs données personnelles
de leurs convictions
ensuite la profession s'est engagée à
réduire la dose le produit
utilisé à l'hectare à côté de ça on a
mis en place ce qu'on appelle le pnr et
plan national de recherche innovation
qui doit permettre justement
d'identifier toutes ces solutions
alternatives à ces produits est efficace
parce qu'il faudra qu on reste quand
même dans un cadre économique où les
agriculteurs devront produire des
betteraves et gagner de l'argent que des
arguments non convaincant pour
l'agriculteur bio ils souhaitent un
changement de paradigme immédiat moi je
prouve un peu regrettable
le choix du gouvernement d'avoir fait un
peu marche arrière la sur les
néonicotinoïdes parce que pour vraiment
essayé de limiter ces pesticides qui
sont utilisés finalement à très faible
dose
comparé à au glyphosate ou en tonnage on
n'est pas du tout sur la même chose est
par contre en hausse 6 me tais par
rapport aux insectes émir supérieur
l'autorisation dérogatoire du
gouvernement prendra fin en 2023 d'ici
là les deux agriculteurs assurent qu'il
n'y aura pas de guerre fratricide entre
pro et anti néonicotinoïdes